for a deeper look at all this we're
joined by CBS news political
correspondent ed O'Keefe who's in our
Washington bureau ed good morning good
morning guys Saturday happy Saturday the
president calls this a
getting-to-know-you meeting plus what's
the plus ed ideally I think it would be
trying to figure out what
denuclearization looks like and maybe as
he suggested discussing the end of the
Korean War
those were either of those would be
significant gets in the first meeting
but notice that in the last few days the
White House has tried to sort of dial
back the expectations saying this is
something that could take several
meetings face-to-face meetings between
Trump and Kim to sort out either way
they're moving forward with it and
pretty incredible that the president
agreed to do this without some assurance
that the Koreans would do something
whether it's begin the denuclearization
process or you know do something about
human rights and the other concerns that
the world community has about Kim's
leadership we've seen Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo sort of take the lead on
this right now ed do we know what type
of preparations the White House is doing
leading up to the summit well there's an
incredible report from The Washington
Post this morning that among other
things they have to sort out who's
paying for chairman Kim's hotel this is
a country that while it's been able to
build up a nuclear weapons program
apparently can't afford to get a few
rooms in Singapore next week and so
they're trying to sort out among other
things who would pay for that whether
it's Singapore whether it's the South
Koreans whether it's the u.s. they're
also discussing details of the meeting
what exactly will they end up discussing
at the table and probably some other
logistical matters remember these are
these have been pretty dramatic meetings
that Kim has held with the South Korean
and Chinese leaders undoubtedly our
president would like to see some
dramatic flourishes when this meeting
happens and this as we've said has been
an on-again off-again on-again summit
with it what are the risks here for the
White House well the big risk is that a
there's another round of will they or
won't they meet which at this late hour
could be a real problem because there's
so many logistical and diplomatic
concerns the other is that they meet and
Kim agrees to nothing and so all it ends
up being is a dramatic photo op which
plays to kim's favor he wants to be seen
as a legitimate leader on the world
stage nothing better than getting a
meeting with the US president
prove that add one other thing that
we've been hearing now the Wall Street
Journal reporting about a potential
summit between the President and
Vladimir Putin do we know anything else
well remember that this actually was
first floated back in March the
president had said that he'd like Putin
to come to Washington we know now that
the Russian ambassador John Huntsman is
working on this but again here what
would they discuss what would be the end
result why do this other than a photo-op
that isn't entirely clear and I want to
talk quickly about the the the 10%
tariff on aluminum and 25% tariff on
steel the president announced this week
the economy is looking pretty strong
right now you're headed into a midterm
why risk a trade war at this point it's
a good question and it's one of the
reasons why so many Republicans House
Speaker Paul Ryan Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell disagree with this
decision and have made that very clear
publicly in the last few days several
states across the Midwest and down in
the south of course rely not only in
agricultural exports but manufacturing
exports and those potential are going to
get hit with retaliatory tariffs from
Canada from Mexico from Europe I talked
to one guy yesterday runs a small
business a porch installation business
here in the Washington area he said he's
already been told by his aluminum
suppliers to expect higher prices if
you're hitting small business owners
like that all across the country
it potentially has an adverse effect on
Republican congressional candidates this
fall and that's why they're very
concerned about what the White House is
doing yeah and and and in any sense of
when people might feel the hurt from
those tariffs them could be feeling it
as soon as this coming week because if
again if you're somebody who's a steel
or aluminum supplier and you've got to
be planning for this the prices could go
up which will trickle down of course to
customers all across the country ed
O'Keefe and our Washington bureau thank
you ed thank you and CBS News we'll have
full coverage of the u.s. North Korean
summit beginning Sunday June 10th CBS
Evening News anchor Jeff Glor will lead
our coverage from Singapore through the
June 12th meeting